Here are the 7 major measures of the new Quebec law
on immigration,
qualified by the left to vote for the
shame and by Marine Le Pen of victory
ideological of his camp.
1st measure,
so far foreigners
whether they work or not
could receive personalized housing assistance
APL,
therefore after 6 months on the French territory.
Well,
now it's after 5 years
for those who do not work and
3 months for those who work.
2nd measure,
in the same way,
so far the benefits
families could be received after 6 months,
well now
they cannot be affected
before 5 years for unemployed foreigners
and before 30 months for those with employment.
3rd measure,
foreign students who
arrive in France will have to pay 1 deposit
when they arrive on the territory,
1 deposit that will be given back to them when they
France.
The amount of this deposit is not yet known.
4th measure,
the right of the ground,
1 historical principle in France
which makes French nationality
is automatically
granted to 1 foreign child born in France,
will no longer be automatic.
It will now be necessary to
make 1 application between the ages of 16 and 18
to benefit from French nationality.
5th measure,
the expulsion
foreigners who have committed crimes or misdemeanors
punished by 3 years or
more imprisonment will be facilitated with this law.
6th measure,
binationals and therefore those who have 2 nationalities.
And who are convicted of homicide
voluntary against
1 custodian person of the public authority.
So for example,
police officers
may lose their French nationality.
7th measure now,
foreigners who do not have a valid residence permit
will be able to pay 1 fine
whereas today it is not alca.
Finally, we can
Note that the government
promised the
Republicans left to reform medical aid
of State
which helps to treat foreigners in situations
irregular.
We will talk about it in another video.